mise à jour économique à québec le
ministre des finances avait plein de
cadeaux pour les ménages aujourd'hui
eric girard qui a annoncé d'abord une
bonification de la location famille la
location passe à 2500 $ pour tous les
enfants de moins de 18 ans abolition
également de la taxe famille la
contribution supplémentaire dans les
tarifs de garderie le tarif redevient
unique beaucoup plus simple à 8 $ 25 par
enfant par jour
et si rétroactif au 1er janvier 2019
baisse des tarifs de stationnement dans
les établissements de santé les deux
premières heures seront gratuites dès le
printemps 2020 et le tarif maximal
quotidien sera de 7 à 10 dollars par
jour pour les patients et les proches
bonification du supplément pour enfant
handicapé qui ont besoin de soins
exceptionnels 650 $ de plus par mois
pour plus de 3000 familles et les
quarante mille citoyens prestataires des
deux derniers recours qui n'avait pas
fait de déclarations de revenus qui
n'avait pas eu le crédit d'impôt pour
solidarité auront droit finalement ce
crédit les revenus sont plus élevés que
prévu à plus de 117 milliards de dollars
dépenses de 113 milliards prévus donc le
surplus passerait à 4 milliards pour
2019 2020 sur plus d'un milliard 400
millions de dollars après le versement
au fonds des générations
le good boy du filaire de la chaire de
recherche en fiscalité et en finances
publiques de l'université de sherbrooke
bonsoir bonsoir avec vous on va aller
plus à fond pour comprendre les mesures
juste un mot d'abord ça fait quoi 20 ans
qu'on bonifie l'aide aux familles à
chaque budget à chaque élection il ya
des promesses les premières sont
toujours ciblé ou souvent ciblées vers
les familles avec enfants
donc il semble que ce soit politiquement
rentable de faire des promesses aux
familles oui les jeunes ménages n'ont
pas encore d'enfants se sentent
concernés par ce qu'ils vont en avoir
plus tard les ménages qui ont des
enfants
les précis et les grands parents qui ont
des petits-enfants apprécié ces mesures
légalement donc droit public cible pour
une même promesse c'est politiquement
rentable et donc on bonifie la location
famille on va présenter un graphique qui
tirait aujourd'hui de la mise à jour
économique du ministre girard pour bien
comprendre ce que ça veut dire
exactement
donc ici ce qu'il faut comprendre
effectivement c'est qu'une bonification
il ya eu une première bonification
l'année passée et on a continué d'être
la bonification cette année
le deuxième et le troisième enfant dans
les allocations familiales étaient moins
payant entre guillemets que le promis on
donnait deux fois moins d'allocations
pour le deuxième et troisième enfin
qu'on a donné pour le premier on vient
corriger la situation
maintenant on donne la même valeur pour
le deuxième ou le troisième enfant et là
on a un exemple avec deux enfants
on voit une bonification en tenant
compte des changements de l'année passée
de cette année cette année 750 mille
dollars
c'est à 500 l'année passée mais le 250 $
de plus pour deux enfants à peu près
jusqu'à jusqu'à 50000 dollars on ait le
maximum
donc ça fait 5700 et 2037 diminue
tranquillement puis on voit qu'il est
allé jusqu à peu près cent dix mille
cent quinze mille on a toujours le gain
le gain maximum des changements de 1250
dollars mais tout le monde est gagnant
même des familles les plus riches ont un
gain parce que maintenant le seuil
minimal et aussi à 1000 $ par enfant et
donc dans ce col avec deux enfants
on aura un gain pour des familles à
revenus de plus de 125 milles de 642 $
de plus nette dans les poches parce que
cette allocation l'homme n'est pas
imposable donc 2500 x 2 5 milles priseur
enfants jusqu'à 50000 qui même en othe
125000 est davantage vous avez encore de
l'argent un minimum de thumeries la
location oui une allocation elle est
universelle donc chacun il ya droit peut
il sans égard au revenu minimum 1000 $
par enfant
mais c'est une bonification tout le
monde a des plus d'argent dans ses
poches suite à la bonification de
location famille dont la location
famille premier point aujourd'hui
deuxième point la contribution
additionnelle
oui sur les tarifs de garderie c'est les
libéraux qui avaient mené seule émission
autour de l'année 2015 en place salle
avait déjà soulevé la grogne d'aix avait
été mise en place
et là évidemment lors de la dernière
campagne
à peu près tous les partis sauf les
libéraux que les met en place promettait
de l'abolir les
la cac avait promis de l'abolir sur
quatre ans l'argent est au rendez-vous
pour elle est abolie au 1er janvier 1er
janvier quoi 2019 de manière rétroactive
donc toute l'année 2019 des gens qui ont
des enfants dans des garderies à
contribution réduite mais qui ont des
revenus élevés qui aurait dû payer cette
contribution additionnelle n'avons pas
le faire donc on revient au tarif unique
de 8 $ 25 par jour l'année 2010 9,8
dollars 25 par jour qui va être indexé
pour l'année 2010 donc dans votre
déclaration de revenus au mois de mars
pour 2019 devrait pas de contribution
césar
donc voici les gains on a pris deux
exemples une famille à 90 milles et une
famille avec en face et le revenu à peu
près médial c'est la famille type un
enfant donc 637 $ d'économies d'impôt si
l'enfant à l'aide en garderait
contribution réduite avec avec la date
et la bonification de l'allocation
familiale également dans ce prénom dans
ce cas là ces jeux juste l'abolition de
l'ex-famille de la taxe famille oui et
ici 957 dollars si on a deux enfants
si on va dans le cas où nous aurions un
revenu plus élevé de 125 mille dollars
voit que le gain est encore supérieure
serait de 2000 $ dans ce colloque pour
l'abolition de la contribution
additionnelle pour frais de garde
donc c'est vraiment juste là qu'on l'a
la taxe famille aboli la bonification de
la question le vus et on est revenu dans
le vert au précédent parfait évidemment
ça ça coûte 200 millions gouvernement
voyez la location famille qu'on a vu
précédemment ces 800 millions
gouvernement donc on parle d'un milliard
les deux annonces pour les deux années
combinée bien regardons d'où vient
l'argent
pourquoi aujourd'hui pourquoi
aujourd'hui on a des sommes
supplémentaires encore une fois six mois
pour le budget oui non plus il faut bien
comprendre ce qu'on a
lorsque le ministre a présenté son
budget en mars jeudi pour l'année en
cours j'ai zéro surplus une fois les
sommes versées au fonds des générations
les vient d'annoncer 850 millions de
mesures additionnelles et malgré tout on
s'enligne vers un surplus d'à-peu-près
1.4 milliard ouais donc les revenus
contre l'économie vaut mieux que prévu
l'économie va bien
1.7 milliard de plus sans revenus
consolidés ouais le gouvernement dépense
plus que prévu dans le budget de mars d
ni 1.4 milliard mais déjà là on a un
gain de 300 millions et les banques
centrales baisse les taux d'intérêt les
banques prêtent à meilleur taux
le gouvernement emprunte sur ses
obligations meilleurs taux il ya une
économie pour la seule année 2010 9 20
il ya une économie plus grande que ce
qu'avaient escomptés en mars dernier de
1.3 milliard c'est considérable
c'est considérable effectivement donc la
marge de manoeuvre elle est là elle est
là elle est circonstanciel cependant les
circonstancielle dans la mesure où si on
dit que l'économie surperforme donc on
est au dessus de notre potentiel
économique
ça veut dire qu'une partie des surplus
qui sont liées à cette conjoncture là et
quand l'économie va retrouver son rythme
plus modeste
les surplus conjoncturelles vont
disparaître parce que le gouvernement
aussi révisé à la hausse ses prévisions
de croissance économique
oui mais ça va bien tu es tellement la
croissance du pib réel pour l'année 2018
2019 et 2020 le québec bell canada
faudra devrait couler assez longuement
en arrière pour retrouver des trois
années consécutives où le québec ait
meilleure croissance économique que la
croissance canadienne absolument merci
beaucoup le football
y'a pas de quoi merci bien